so moralist story is your street style
she got it going on got it going on
I mean y'all got work to do we're
co-stars we're co-stars for a reason
absolutely okay Tyrese yes ma'am I gotta
give you props Roman finally got a
chance to get his day to lead a mission
you know
we'd already be there if Roman wasn't
driving Fort Knox on wheels
baby
I feel that I was finally in charge and
doing my thing yeah I was happy about it
in charge yeah I was happy about it in
charge I mean really because Roman you
know it's like the Rodney Dangerfield
and the fast franchise
I love it thanks you're having way too
much
yeah how much though does Roman like
being the boss I loved it now the thing
is when you are a leader and yet an
insecure leader
even when you have doubt you're not
supposed to show it that's one of the
things that I figured out uh because
they're all looking to me like okay
you're leading now right what do we do
uh yeah that
saw that look a couple times
that's kind of it now doesn't 70
. I'm gonna let this one go I'm very
happy that Raymond got to take the Take
the Lead yeah see see and then we're all
still safe you know we're not in outer
space or anything we're still on the
ground everybody's still looking no
scratches no bruises everything's fine
still no scratches still no bruises
great leader I mean it also helps that
his team are like really com like
competent yeah there we go skill there
we go
sometimes you gotta let people think
they're leading oh yeah right
now
so by the way thank you for coming back
we're happy to see you back again we
missed you in nine what was it like to
get the call and say hey come hang with
the gang again
happy I'm back yeah
Honestly though I mean did you be
playing I don't know what they call you
little nobody
so the the fact that you got that call
to come back and play him again what was
that no it was super fun it's it's
always great to be with this you know
is it's a real fun fun franchise to be a
part of
every time we do it we have a good time
yeah I want to connect a little bit with
you Natalie on here because I love this
franchise so much and I have since the
very very beginning but I think the one
thing that always kind of bothered me is
that this The Narrative that has been
painted is that it's like a guy film and
this film has so much like badass female
energy oh yeah in it for sure and like
female star power so I'm just wondering
like talk about how the women have
really helped you know bring this
franchise to another level and success
at the box office
um I think there's definitely been a
rebalancing
um from previous films um when it comes
to the uh women and their representation
and I think like what's so fantastic
about the women in this film in these
films but this film is as as well is
that we all bring something so different
and we are women that are not doing what
may be the world or the people around
them think they should necessarily be
doing and um I always
um you know I think it's quite commonly
said like if you see it you can be it or
see it you can become it and I think
that
seeing women be so have so much agency
so much strength so much power so much
like ability and being really competent
and like you know fearless and
courageous and all of that I think is
just
it's such an important thing to see in
the world yeah yeah and obviously we
have incredible like women in these
movies like it's the talent is it's
bananas it really really is and I but I
still have these kind of arguments
sometimes with my girlfriends about
seeing the this film because they're
like I'm not I don't want to see any I'm
like you don't understand these films
are for everyone yeah yeah
yeah they are
um but they're they're for everyone in
the capacity of
just really feeling like wow we've been
in this for 20 years and
people were in elementary junior high
school now they're adults with wives and
kids and so everyone is going to the
theater to see this
um it's a real
fast tradition family thing okay for all
of you all your favorite action sequence
of this movie
I mean the Rome sequence is pretty like
just a feeling yeah
that's the ball all right dorks what are
we blowing up what the Vatican
you guys are going to hell
I think
uh I would say when Ben came out of the
plane and landed on the freeway yeah
that was uh that was pretty cool that
was pretty damn epic I haven't seen the
movie I haven't seen it yet well young
Jedi we gotta get you in the future like
full disclosure I haven't seen it either
um but I just like from from the from
the trailer
um but I will say that um
yeah just like from the story like I
think just I would love the the whole
set piece set piece of rainbows I have
to tell you I never thought anything
could top seven for me
y'all this film this movie is yes
foreign